so I'm sure you've been razzle dazzled
by the hunter and its golden gun for the
warlock with its nova bombs I'm here to
tell you that the Titan is the Hulk of
the Guardians remember what the hole did
to Loki yeah that's what the Titan will
give you if that doesn't pique your
interest then the Titans second subclass
the defender makes you the ultimate tank
for you and your teammate if you want to
become a Titan here's more about both of
its subclasses starting subclass where
the Titan is a striker the striker is
the more offensive of the two subclasses
and gives you the ability to clear out
enemies with ease the striker special
move is the fist of havoc which is a
leaping ground slam that kills foes
within the blast radius this of havoc is
especially good for clearing out waves
of minions during an objective hold or
during a boss battle in addition this
skill is greatly useful in the crucible
as it allows you to take out multiple
Guardians that are clustered together
especially in the control zone game type
with our big areas of contention be
careful when using this ability at low
health though because there will be
times when you'll die during the casting
animation and then you'll lose your
overcharge another aspect that
differentiates the subclasses organ AIDS
the Titans primary grenade is a
flashbang that disorients your enemies
you'll know that that are flash because
they'll have a red cloud over their head
that make them easy targets to close in
on with a shotgun or a melee strike the
secondary grenade is a pulse grenade
which periodically damages enemies
inside its explosion radius this grenade
doesn't seem a strong though because
it's easily avoidable finish off any
stragglers with your strong melee
ability of the storm fist which seals
bonus melee damage watch the cooldown on
storm fist though or you won't pack that
extra wallop you normally do you can
even turn yourself into a juggernaut so
to speak as you run you'll pick up
momentum and once you've acquired a
target let your melee trigger rip and
send your opponent's flying with a
running shoulder tackle the shoulder
tackle is an upgrade further along in
the Stryker skill tree if this style
doesn't suit you choose a more defensive
support subclass of the Titan the
defender the defender special is the
ward of dawn which creates a large
bubble that is impenetrable to bullets
rockets lasers and more use this to
revive your fallen teammates for in a
pinch when you're surrounded and running
low on health the ward of dawn can be
upgraded to last longer and later down
the road it can buff your teammates as
well
the only drawback to the ward of dawn is
you can't shoot from within the bubble
however if the enemies walk into the
bubble
you can melee them with no fear as
you'll stay relatively invulnerable this
is a good tactic when being surrounded
by lesser mobs let them walk in and play
Rock'em Sock'em robots even more reason
to kill your opponents with your melee
ability is the fact that the defenders
melee skill disintegrates gives you a
force barrier that absorbs incoming
damage you'll know you have this active
by your glowing purple hand this skill
can also be used in a pinch as well to
help you stay alive if you're low on
health as the shield effect will mask
your low life the interesting thing
about the defender is the grenade
ability it gets the magnetic grenade
sticks to either the enemy or the
surface that you threw it at and
explodes twice the grenade can then be
upgraded to shoot out a void of light or
charges of energy you can stick these
grenades in any direction horizontal
vertical or diagonal depending on how
you throw it this can then be used to
zone out mobs or players in PvP the
tanks double jump is the same for both
subclasses and on first upgrade allows
you to ascend higher into the air this
skill is subpar because you end up
floating in the air making you an easy
target to pick off the upgraded
controlled double jump is much better
however as it allows you to control
which direction you want to boost you in
the air this is especially good if you
know a rocket or big damage is coming to
your side as you can boost your way into
the other direction the time class gives
you the flexibility to play two very
distinct styles they'll cater to your
needs or to the needs at hand
just make sure whichever one you're more
interested in is the one you level first
as you have to level these separately in
addition when you first pick up the
defender subclass you'll have to start
leveling from scratch that's right no
double jump or grenades right off the
bat to help level the freshly unlocked
defender subclass complete bounties as a
striker but then switch to the defender
before cashing them in whatever class
weapons and gear you have equipped when
you're actually turning your bounties
will receive the XP boost as well it'll
be interesting to see if the defender
becomes more useful when raids come out
as a difficulty will likely increase
with more players and enemies in the mix
as currently I personally still prefer
the striker subclass because who doesn't
want to channel their inner Hulk this is
the fight it's a mess
you